okay
the sound of the explosion
the calls for help
the panic and confusion what should have
followed was in the words of the
chairman of the public inquiry an
effective coordinated multi-agency
response that he said is not what
happened
we heard heartbreaking evidence
of the injured and The Rescuers who were
in the city room
hearing the Sirens of ambulances
knowing paramedics were close by
expecting their imminent arrival
only for them not to arrive those delays
prove fatal to John Atkinson his family
now know he would probably have survived
with proper treatment as we know from
Witnesses
John kept asking
causes us to say that is too great to
put into words
with the family of the youngest victim
eight-year-old sathy Rose russos filmed
here on that night disagreed with the
finding that earlier treatment wouldn't
have saved her
she died through the loss of blood
and her injuries of course but a cause
of death was loss of blood
now if you leave a person that's
bleeding and don't give them the
immediate
medical attention that they require then
of course they're going to die she's a
fighter like a mum she would fight to
the end and again for the family of
Martin head the hope is that the
inquiry's recommendations will make a
difference I don't want any of them to
have died for nothing
what's really reassuring is that Sir
John is actually going to follow up some
of these things to make sure they are
actually carried out and that is
reassuring
the Emergency Services came to repeat
their apologies for a catalog of
mistakes they say changes have been made
if this were to happen again tomorrow
how do you reassure the public that some
of these mistakes all of these mistakes
wouldn't be made again God forbid we
should have to do this again
that some of the things that went wrong
almost as a domino from not getting it
right at the outset would just not
happen again even though the Threat
Level was very high in May 2017 the
chairman said no one in Authority really
thought it could happen to them they
were wrong and five years on so many are
still paying the price Greg Milam Sky
News Manchester